there's a growing number of people that
live out of their cars in King County
why haven't you created some maybe safe
parking lots for for some of these
individuals well you know the cities who
have the jurisdiction locally have been
really struggling with this and I know
the city of Seattle is going has been
doing some work on making sure that
there are places where people can safely
park camp in their cars what about the
rest of the county well we have 39
cities in the county so most of the
areas where people are in their cars are
within those cities and those cities
have local authority so the county does
not have any authority over people
living in in their car yeah we do in the
in the rural area in the unincorporated
area but again most of that is within
city jurisdiction most of the services
for the homeless are for people who
aren't shelters or people that are
living on the streets living in camps
but not so much for those living in
their cars what are you doing what is
the county doing to help some of those
people transition into a permanent home
you know it's a really interesting
question we set up a set of services
that are designed to reach out to people
who are living either on the streets or
in cars tent encampments etcetera with a
set of services including for those who
are struggling with opioid addiction
interventions to get them onto medically
assisted treatment we recognize that not
everyone is going to have the the
wherewithal or the the time and ability
to come into a bricks-and-mortar
facility get the services they need all
home set a goal to end chronic
homelessness by 2015 ending veterans
homelessness by 2017 and ending youth
and family homelessness by 2020
it's almost 2020 and the first two were
not met should we believe that anything
would be done was this too ambitious of
a program it was very ambitious and I
think the challenge is not that they
they were not successful but rather that
the challenges that are causing
homelessness continued to grow the
national income inequality the crisis
and mental health and opioid addiction
and locally the very strained housing
market in this boom economy all of those
things are conspiring because more and
more people to become homeless we have
to join together to deal with the
challenges that individuals are having
that are causing them become homeless to
make sure they get out of homelessness
quickly and to make sure they don't come
back into it